BUT FIRST IT'S TIME FOR
TONIGHT'S BREAKING NEWS, THE
OPENING MONOLOGUE.
STORM ASKED LET'S BE HONEST,
BORDER SECURITY IS A DEADLY
SERIOUS ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO THE SENATE FOR
IMMIGRATION STUDIES SINCE 2001,
15 SUSPECTED TERRORISTS HAVE
BEEN APPREHENDED AT OUR SOUTHERN
BORDER INCLUDING ISLAMIC
EXTREMISTS FROM AL-SHABAAB, AND
ISIS.
MEANWHILE, OVER 25,000 OTHER
KNOWN CRIMINAL IMMIGRANTS HAVE
BEEN ARRESTED SINCE 2016.
THIS INCLUDES OVER A DOZEN
MURDERERS.
370 CONVICTED SEX OFFENDERS AND
NEARLY 5,000 INDIVIDUALS
CONVICTED OF ILLEGAL DRUGS OR
WEAPONS CHARGES.
NOW OF COURSE I WOULD TELL YOU
THAT THE VAST MAJORITY OF PEOPLE
WHO WENT ACROSS THE BORDER
ILLEGALLY PROBABLY ARE PEOPLE
THAT WANT A BETTER LIFE FOR
THEMSELVES OR THEIR FAMILY BUT
EVEN THE ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS WITH
THE BEST OF INTENTIONS ARE
COSTING THE TAXPAYERS AN
ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF MONEY.
ACCORDING TO A RECENT STUDY,
EVERY ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT THAT
SUCCESSFULLY CROSSES ALL BORDER
COSTS YOU WILL COME OF THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, $70,000 PER
YEAR.
ON DECEMBER 3RD, OVER 3,000
PEOPLE WERE CAUGHT ILLEGALLY
CROSSING IN JUST ONE DAY.
IN NOVEMBER OF 2-YEAR-OLD
TODDLER WAS FOUND CROSSING THE
BORDER WITHOUT HER PARENTS.
WE MUST HAVE THE ABILITY TO
DECIDE WHO COMES INTO OUR
COUNTRY TO ENSURE THE SAFETY ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE ORDER, THE
EVENT PEOPLE AND MAKE SURE THEY
CAN TAKE CARE OF THEMSELVES.
SO NOW MORE THAN EVER WE NEED A
MASSIVE WALL.
IT'S A COMMON SENSE STRATEGY
THAT ACTUALLY WORKS, KEEPING
POTENTIAL TERRORISTS AND THOSE
THAT ARE CRIMINALS, HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS AND DRUG TRAFFICKERS
OUT OF THIS COUNTRY.
THAT'S A NATIONAL SECURITY
ISSUE.
THE PRESIDENT HAS LONG PROMISED
TO BUILD THE WALL AND NOW HE'S
FIGHTING TO DO JUST THAT, HE'S
FIGHTING FOR WHAT'S RIGHT.
HE FOUGHT HARD AND THIS IS HIS
HISTORY FOR TAX CUTS.
HE FOUGHT FOR NEW TRADE DEALS
AND HE'S WAITING ON THAT FRONT.
HE FOUGHT BACK AGAINST OBAMA'S
AND LESS BUREAUCRATIC
REGULATIONS AND HE HAS CREATED
AN ENVIRONMENT FOR BUSINESSES
THAT ARE NOW THRIVING.
HE FOUGHT FOR ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE AND FOR THE FIRST
TIME THIS WEEK, AND 75 YEARS, WE
ARE ENERGY INDEPENDENT.
HE FOUGHT FOR THE CONFIRMATION
OF QUALIFIED ORIGINALISTS,
JUSTICES AND HE HAS ONE AND NOW
HE'S FIGHTING FOR THE WALL ON
THE SOUTHERN BORDER IN A BIG WAY
AND CONFRONTING NANCY PELOSI AND
CHUCK SCHUMER FOR PLAYING
POLITICS WITH WHAT IS THE SAFETY
AND SECURITY OF EVERY AMERICAN
CITIZEN.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> President Trump: I WOULD
LIKE TO NOT SEE A GOVERNMENT
CLOSING THE SHUT DOWN.
WE SEE WHAT HAPPENS OVER THE
NEXT PERIOD OF TIME.
BORDER SECURITY IS EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT AND WE HAVE TO TAKE
CARE OF BORDER SECURITY.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHAT HAPPENED
WITH THE CARAVANS, WITH THE
PEOPLE, WE SHUT IT DOWN.
WE HAD NO CHOICE, WE SHUT IT
DOWN.
IT COULD BE A LOT EASIER IF WE
HAD REAL BORDER SECURITY.
>> YOU HAVE THE WHITE HOUSE.
YOU HAVE THE SENATE.
YOU HOW TO    HAVE THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> WE COULD BRING IT UP RIGHT
NOW TODAY.
>> President Trump: I CAN'T
GET IT PASSED IN THE HOUSE IF
IT'S NOT GOING TO PASS IN THE
SENATE.
>> WHILE YOU CAN GET IT STARTED
THAT WAY.
SPEAK TO THE HOUSE WE CAN GET
PASSED VERY EASILY AND WE DO.
THE PROBLEM IS THE SENATE
BECAUSE WE NEED TEN DEMOCRATS TO
VOTE.
WE NEED BORDER SECURITY.
PEOPLE ARE POURING INTO OUR
COUNTRY INCLUDING TERRORISTS.
WE CAUGHT TEN TERRORISTS OVER
THE LAST SHORT PERIOD OF TIME.
THESE ARE VERY SERIOUS PEOPLE.
OUR BORDER AGENTS, ALL OF OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT HAS BEEN
INCREDIBLE BUT WE CAUGHT TEN
TERRORISTS, PEOPLE LOOKING TO DO
HARM.
WE NEED BORDER SECURITY, OF
WHICH THE WALL IS JUST A PIECE.
>> YOU SAY MY WAY OR WE WILL
SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
WE HAVE A PROPOSAL THAT
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WILL
SUPPORT, TO DO A CR, THAT WILL
NOT SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
>> President Trump: AND IF
IT'S NOT GOOD BORDER SECURITY I
WON'T TAKE IT.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOOK AT THESE
NUMBERS AND YOU LOOK AT THE JOB
THAT WE ARE DOING -- CAN I TELL
YOU SOMETHING?
>> YES, YOU JUST SAID IT.
SPEAK TO WHEN YOU HAVE WALLS,
IT'S EFFECTIVE.
WHEN YOU DON'T HAVE WALLS IT'S
NOT EFFECTIVE.
>> WE CAME HERE IN GOOD FAITH
AND ENTERING INTO A DISCUSSION
OF THE PUBLIC VIEW.
SPEAK TO IT'S CALLED
TRANSPARENCY.
>> IT'S NOT TRANSPARENCY WHEN WE
ARE NOT STIPULATED TO A SET OF
FACTS AND WE WANT TO HAVE A
DEBATE WITH YOU.
>> President Trump: WE NEED
BORDER SECURITY.
>> 20 TIMES HE WILL CALL FOR IT,
I WILL SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT
IF I DON'T GET MY WILL.
>> YOU SAID IT.
>> President Trump: YOU KNOW
WHAT I WILL SAY?
IF WE DON'T GET WHAT WE WANT ONE
WAY OR THE OTHER WHETHER IT'S
THROUGH YOU OR IN THE MILITARY
OR ANYTHING YOU WANT TO CALL, I
WILL SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
AND I AM PROUD, I'M PROUD TO
SHUTDOWN THE GOVERNMENT WITH
BORDER SECURITY.
>> Sean: CHECK COULDN'T EVEN
LOOK HIM IN THE EYE.
FOX NEWS HAS CONFIRMED THAT FOX
REPUBLICANS ARE CONSIDERING
PUTTING A $5 MILLION FUNDING THE
WALL BUILT UP FOR THAT VOTE THAT
NANCY PELOSI WANTS AND THEY WILL
STILL FUND THE GOVERNMENT AT
CURRENT LEVELS.
THIS BILL WOULD PROVE
NANCY PELOSI WRONG AND PUT
SENATE DEMOCRATS IN A PRETTY
PRECARIOUS POSITION.
NEITHER FUND THE WALL OR THEY
WOULD SHUT DOWN THE GOVERNMENT.
BY THE WAY, IF YOU ARE A
REPUBLICAN IN CONGRESS AND YOU
VOTE NO, I WILL TELL YOU RIGHT
NOW THAT WE WILL BE HIGHLIGHTING
YOUR NAME AND YOUR RECORD AND
HOLDING YOU ALL ACCOUNTABLE.
THIS IS ABOUT OUR NATION
SECURITY.
IT'S ABOUT STOPPING DRUG
TRAFFICKERS AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKERS, IT'S ABOUT SAFETY
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
NONE OF THIS SEEMS TO MATTER TO
THE LEFT AND YET AGAIN, THEY ARE
ON THE WRONG SIDE OF WHAT IS A
MONUMENTALLY IMPORTANT ISSUE.
ACCORDING TO A HARVARD HARRIS
POLL, A MAJORITY OF AMERICANS
SUPPORT THE PRESIDENT.
79% WANT MORE SECURE BORDERS.
AND 68% WANT AN END TO THE VISA
LOTTERY SYSTEM.
DEMOCRATS DON'T WANT TO LISTEN
TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, MAYBE
THEY SHOULD LISTEN TO THEMSELVES
BECAUSE THEY ARE SUCH HYPOCRITE
HYPOCRITES, THEY SOUND A LOT
LIKE DONALD TRUMP AND WE HAVE
THE TAPE TO PROVE IT.
>> WEAVES VENT MONEY TO SPEND A
MAKE A BARRIER TO TRY TO PREVENT
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS FOR COMING I
IN.
>> PEOPLE WHO ENTERED THE
UNITED STATES WITHOUT OUR
PERMISSION ARE ILLEGAL ALIENS
AND ILLEGAL ALIENS SHOULD NOT BE
TREATED THE SAME AS PEOPLE WHO
ENTER THE U.S. LEGALLY.
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE NEVER ACCEPT
IMMIGRATION REFORM UNLESS THEY
TRULY BELIEVE THERE GOVERNMENT
IS COMMITTED TO ENDING FUTURE
IMMIGRATION.
>> BECAUSE WE LIVE IN AN AGE
WHERE TERRORISTS ARE TERRORIZING
OUR BORDERS, WE CANNOT ALLOW
PEOPLE TO POUR INTO THE U.S.
UNDETECTED, UNDOCUMENTED AND
UNCHECKED.
>> Sean: HOW TIMES HAVE
CHANGED, THEY SOUNDED LIKE BABY
DONALD TRUMP.
NOW THEY WANT OPEN BORDERS.
SANCTUARY CITIES, SANCTUARY
STATES, THEY WANT TO GET RID OF
A I.C.E. AND ALL THE HARD WORK
THAT THEY DO ALTOGETHER.
IT WAS ONE OF THE MORE
FASCINATING MOMENTS, THEY KEPT
URGING THE PRESIDENT OVER AND
OVER.
CAN WE TALK PRIVATELY?
PLEASE?
THAT'S A SURE SIGN THAT THEY
KNEW THEY WERE OUT OF TOUCH WITH
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
CAN WE PLEASE DO THIS PRIVATELY?
PRETTY PLEASE?
TAKE A LOOK.
>> AT THE POINT IS, THERE ARE
EQUITIES TO BE WAIVED AND WE ARE
HERE TO HAVE A CONVERSATION IN A
PRAYERFUL WAY, SO I DON'T THINK
WE SHOULD HAVE A DEBATE IN FRONT
OF THE PRESS.
LET US HAVE OUR CONVERSATION.
>> THAT'S OUR PROPOSAL.
IF IT'S GOOD THEN COME IT'S GOOD
NOW AND IT WON'T SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> President Trump: WE COULD
BUILD A MUCH BIGGER SECTION WITH
MORE MONEY.
>> LETS DEBATE IN PRIVATE.
>> WE CAME IN HERE IN GOOD
FAITH, AND WE ARE ENTERING INTO
THIS KIND OF DISCUSSION WITH THE
PUBLIC.
>> President Trump: IT'S NOT
BAD, NANCY.
IT'S CALLED TRANSPARENCY.
>> LET'S HAVE A CONVERSATION
WHERE WE DON'T HAVE TO
CONTRADICT IN PUBLIC THE
STATISTICS THAT YOU PUT FORTH
BUT INSTEAD IT'S A CONVERSATION
ABOUT WHAT WOULD REALLY WORK.
>> Sean: LET'S HAVE THE
CONVERSATION IN PUBLIC, AND
INSTEAD OF WORKING TOWARDS A
SOLUTION, AND MOMENTS AFTER THAT
TENSE EXCHANGE IN THE
WHITE HOUSE, AND THAT THE TIME
OF ECONOMIC UNCERTAINTY, AND THE
MARKET IN THE MOVE, AND THE
LUXURY -- TRUMP SHUT DOWN.
>> IF HE STICKS TO HIS POSITION
FOR A $5 BILLION WALL, HE WILL
GET NO WALL AND HE WILL GET THE
SHUT DOWN.
THIS TRUMP SHUT DOWN, THIS
TEMPER TANTRUM THAT HE SEEMS TO
THROW WILL NOT GET HIM HIS WALL
AND HE WILL HURT A LOT OF PEOPLE
BECAUSE HE WILL CAUSE THE SHUT
DOWN.
HE ADMITTED HE WANTED THE SHUT
DOWN AND IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE
THAT HE WOULD WANT THAT.
THE PRESIDENT SAID THINGS ARE
WORKING QUITE WELL AT THE BORDER
BUT WE WANT TO GIVE HIM THE SAME
THING HE HAD LAST YEAR.
IF THEY WORK WELL LAST YEAR THEY
SHOULD WORK WELL THIS YEAR AND
IT SHOULDN'T SHUT DOWN THE
GOVERNMENT.
>> AMAZING, CHECK COULDN'T LOOK
HIM IN THE EYE WHEN IT COMES
RIGHT IN FRONT OF HIM BUT HE
DOESN'T HAVE ANYBODY TO DEBATE
OR REFUTE WHAT HE'S SAYING.
ACTUALLY, CHUCK, THE PRESIDENT
SAID HE WOULD OWN IT, HE'S
WILLING TO FIGHT FOR HIS PROMISE
FOR THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AND THAT
NATIONAL SECURITY IS THAT
IMPORTANT TO HIM.
HE SAYS HE OWNS IT.
AND NANCY PELOSI GETS BACK TO
THE SECURITY OF CAPITOL HILL.
HE ACTUALLY THEN QUESTIONED THE
PRESIDENT'S MANHOOD, TELLING HER
FELLOW DEMOCRATS, IT'S LIKE A
MANHOOD THING FOR HIM.
AS IF MANHOOD COULD EVER BE
ASSOCIATED WITH HIM.
THIS WALL THING THAT SHOWS YOU I
GET INTO A TINKLE CONTEST WITH
THE SKUNK AND YOU GET TINGLE ALL
OVER YOU.
THAT'S THE LEADER OF THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY.
YOU WATCH IN THE FIRST THREE
MONTHS, THIS WILL BE
ENTERTAINMENT AT ITS HIGHEST
LEVEL.
LET'S CONTRAST THOSE PETTY
STATEMENTS.
>> President Trump: I DON'T
MIGHT HAVE AN ISSUE OF BORDER
SECURITY ON MY SIDE.
IF WE HAVE TO CLOSE DOWN THE
COUNTRY OVER BORDER SECURITY, I
ACTUALLY LIKE THAT IN TERMS OF
AN ISSUE BUT I DON'T WANT IT TO
BE AN ISSUE.
I WANTED TO BE SOMETHING THAT
THE COUNTRY NEEDS THAT'S NOT
REALLY AN ISSUE, BUT IT'S COMMON
SENSE IN THE COUNTRY NEEDS IT.
WE NEED PROTECTION.
WE NEED BORDER SECURITY.
WE NEED SECURITY FROM DRUGS THAT
ARE POURING INTO OUR COUNTRY
COMING IN RIGHT THROUGH THAT
SOUTHERN BORDER.
WE NEED A WALL, AND PART OF
BORDER SECURITY IS THE WALL.
CHUCK'S PROBLEM IS, WHEN WE LAST
CLOSED IT DOWN, THAT WAS HIS
IDEA AND HONESTLY, HE GOT
KILLED.
HE DOESN'T WANT TO OWN IT.
AND I SAID RATHER THAN US
DEBATING WHO'S OWNING IT, I WILL
TAKE IT.
WE CLOSED DOWN THE COUNTRY, I
WILL TAKE IT, BECAUSE WE ARE
CLOSING IT DOWN FOR BORDER
SECURITY AND I THINK I WIN THAT
EVERY SINGLE TIME.
>> Sean: OWNERSHIP,
RESPONSIBILITY, KEEPING PROMISES
AND THE COURAGE TO FIGHT BACK
ALL WHILE SOME CRITICIZE A
PRESENT STYLE.
THIS IS WHY THE BORDER WALL WILL
GET DONE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
HE IS THE DISRUPTOR IN CHIEF AND
FINALLY PROMISES THAT ARE MADE
THAT ARE BEING KEPT.
THAT'S THE SAME REASON WHY THE
BIPARTISAN PRISON REFORM BILL
WILL LIKELY PASS CONGRESS AND
BECOME LAW.
SOON, NONVIOLENT, LOW RISK
OFFENDERS WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO
CONTRIBUTE TO SOCIETY WITHOUT
UNREASONABLY LONG PRISON
SENTENCES.
THIS IS GOOD FOR AMERICA.
EVERYONE IS AGAIN NONVIOLENT,
VERY IMPORTANT, ESPECIALLY THOSE
WHO ARE FIRST-TIME OFFENDERS.
WE SHOULD HAVE A CHANCE AT
REDEMPTION.
MEMBER THIS SCENE, THINKING THE
PRESIDENT AND THINKING THE
COUNTRY FOR THE SECOND CHANCE.
HE SPENT 20 PLUS YEARS IN PRISON
FOR ONE DRUG OFFENSE, AND NOW
OTHERS LIKE ALICE MARIE JOHNSON
CURRENTLY IN PRISON AND THEY
WILL BE GIVEN A SECOND CHANCE.
DESPITE REAL PROGRESS ACROSS THE
COUNTRY ON MULTIPLE FRONTS,
TRUMP DERANGEMENT SYNDROME HAS
DEVASTATED SOME OF AMERICA'S
WORST SO-CALLED JOURNALISTS.
OF COURSE THAT INCLUDES
"NEW YORK TIMES" HACKED PAUL
KRUGMAN.
THIS IS THE MOST INSANE THING I
THINK I HAVE READ IN
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" AND THAT
SAYS A LOT.
THAT'S TWEETING OUT AN ARTICLE
ALONG WITH CLIMATE CHANGE.
AND PAPER FILLED WITH ANTI-TRUMP
RAGE THAT EMPLOYS A PERSON THAT
CALLS THE UNITED STATES OF
AMERICA EVIL?
IT'S ALSO MISPLACED.
MR. KRUGMAN IN 2017, THE U.S.
ACTUALLY LET ALL COUNTRIES IN
REDUCING CARBON EMISSIONS.
I GUESS JOURNALISM IS NOT ONE OF
HIS STRENGTHS.
WHAT ELSE WOULD YOU EXPECT FROM
"THE NEW YORK TIMES"?
AND FOR THE RECORD, PAUL,
AMERICA IS NOT PERFECT, NO
COUNTRY HAS EVER BEEN BUT
THERE'S NEVER BEEN A COUNTRY
THAT HAS ACCUMULATED MORE POWER
AND ABUSED IT LESS AND ACUTELY
DID MORE POWER AND IT USED IT TO